[MUSIC]
What we found was that organizations that
had strong norms for
adaptability that were widely shared and
strongly held.
Those organizations perform much better.
They perform better in terms of net income
growth.
They perform better in terms of revenue
They perform better in terms of the
market-to-book value of the company.
They perform better in terms of employee
ratings.
And they perform better in terms of a,
analyst recommendations to buy the stock.
So this was, this is really the first
study that demonstrates, conclusively,
that there are very clear relationships
between culture in an organization, and
firm performance.
[MUSIC]
It includes things like willingness to
experiment.
Being quick to opportunities.
Being flexible.
Being willing to tolerate some failure.
So, all these are specific behaviors, that
I think managers can be thinking about,
when they're encouraging people to, to, to
be adaptable.
So, it's not just a, a global label that,
that means nothing.
It has some very concrete meaning, that
can be managed.
[MUSIC]
When managers think about culture in
organizations, they should be sensitive to
the fact that what they're really trying
to do are create norms,
create expectations among employees around
this notion of adaptability, and
to make sure that those norms are widely
shared within the organization.
We've actually looked at how managers
create cultures and
there are really 4 big mechanisms that
managers use.
First of all, the signals that they send,
that is,
the questions they ask, where they spend
their time.
So, what are the messages that they are
sending, through both their words and
their, and their actions.
The second lever that we talk about is the
involvement of people,
getting people engaged so
that people understand that what they're,
what they're doing is important.
The third big lever that managers used to
shape culture has to do with the vivid
illustrations that they send to people,
sort of what gets held up as exemplary,
what, what is recognized and approved of.
And the fourth lever is, has to do with
rewards.
But typically not money.
Money is not a particularly good way to
shape culture.
When we talk about rewards, we're really
talking about what gets recognized,
what gets approved.
I mean, one of the companies we looked at,
they, they explicitly talk about honoring
people who share the values.
So, think about those four levers as a
manager.
Then, what I can do is I can use these
four levers to think about what
are the signals I'm sending about.
Is it okay to explore new avenues?
Is it okay to take the initiative?
Is it okay to be fast?
Is it okay?
And if you use those four levers and you
constantly repeat the messages,
then people will begin to understand that,
look, this is important.
You know, Jack Welch said something
interesting about culture.
He said, most managers fail at managing
culture because they get bored.
I mean we, we give the same talk five
times and we want to give another talk.
And what Will says, if you want to be
affective at managing culture,
you've got to be two things as a manager.
You have to be relentless, you have to be
boring.
What he meant by that is, you have to
repeat again, again, and
again these messages.
So the extent in which managers in
organizations constantly
reinforce to their employees that we want
you to, to take small risks.
We want you to try new things.
We want you to sort of take the
initiative.
That's what creates this, this culture of
adaptability.
[MUSIC]
Culture can be a real competitive
advantage or a competitive disadvantage.
And a question I think for managers, is to
really think hard about what the culture
is that you need to execute your strategy?
In that process, the culture that works
for
today's strategy may not work as the world
changes.
And therefore, the key to long term
success is to
have a culture that's aligned with your
strategy but
also has embedded in it, norms that
promote adaptability.
If you, if you think about organizations
that survive for
long periods, they're around today only
because they had
leaders who were able to help them succeed
in the short term in one environment.
And then as the world changed to help them
shift to a new a new alignment of culture.
And at, the norms for adaptability are
what we believe help them do that.
[MUSIC]